I'm wondering what would be the single
most valuable piece of advice you give
us to even attempt to create some of the
value that you guys have done in both
your very impressive companies people
say you you have to have a lot of
passion for what you're doing and it's
totally true and the reason is is
because it's so hard that if you don't
any rational person would give up it's
really hard and you have to do it over a
sustained period of time so if you don't
love it if you're not having fun doing
it you don't really love it you're going
to give up
and that's what happens to most people
actually if you really look at the ones
that ended up you know being successful
unquote in the eyes of society and the
ones that didn't oftentimes it's the
ones that are successful love what they
did so they could persevere when you
know when it got really tough and and
the ones that didn't love it quit
because they're saying right who would
want to put up with this stuff if you
don't love it so it's a lot of hard work
and and it's a lot of worrying
constantly and if you don't love it
you're going to fail so you got to love
it you got to have passion